as you mentioned modular is very new
Mojo is very new it's a relatively small
team yeah it's building up this gigantic
stack this incredible stack that's going
to perhaps Define the future of
development of our AI overlords uh we
just hope it will be useful
as do all of us uh so what uh what have
you learned from this process of
building up a team maybe one question is
how do you hire
great programmers great people that
operate in this
compiler Hardware machine learning
software interface design space yeah and
maybe are a little bit fluid yeah what
they can do so okay so language design
too so building a company is just as
interesting in different ways is
building a language like different skill
sets different things but super
interesting and I've built a lot of
teams in a lot of different places
um if you zoom in from the big problem
into recruiting
well so here's our problem okay I'll
I'll just I'll be very straightforward
about this we started modular with a lot
of conviction about we understand the
problems we understand the customer pain
points we need to work backwards from
the suffering in the industry and if we
solve those problems we think it'll be
useful for people
but the problem is is that the people we
need to hire as you say are all these
super specialized people that have jobs
at Big Tech big Tech worlds right and
you know we I don't think we have
um product Market fit in the way that a
normal startup does we don't have
product Market fit challenges because
right now everybody's using Ai and so
many of them are suffering and they want
help and so again we started with strong
conviction now again you have to hire
and recruit the best and the best all
have jobs and so what we've done is we
said okay well let's build an amazing
culture
start with that that's usually not
something a company starts with usually
you hire a bunch of people and then it
people start fighting and it turns into
gigantic mess and then you try to figure
out how to improve your culture later my
co-founder Tim in particular is super
passionate about making sure that that's
right and we've spent a lot of time
early on to make sure that we can scale
can you comment aside before we get to
the second yeah what makes for a good
culture
um so I mean there's many different
cultures and I have learned many things
from
several very unique almost famously
unique cultures and some of them I
learned what to do and some of them I
learned what not to do yep okay and so
um
we want an inclusive culture uh I
believe in like amazing people working
together
and so I've seen cultures where people
you have amazing people and they're
fighting each other
I see amazing people and they're told
what to do like Thou shalt line up and
do what I say it doesn't matter if it's
the right thing do it right and neither
of these is the and I've seen people
that have no Direction they're just kind
of floating in different places and they
want to be amazing they just don't know
how and so a lot of it starts with have
a Clear Vision
right and so we have a clear vision of
what we're doing and so I kind of grew
up at Apple in my engineering life right
and so a lot of the Apple DNA rubbed off
on me my co-founder Tim also is like a
strong product guy and so what we
learned is you know I was taught at
Apple that you don't work from building
cool technology you don't work from like
come up with a cool product and think
about the features you'll have in the
big check boxes and stuff like this
because if you go talk to customers they
don't actually care about your product
they don't care about your technology
what they care about is their problems
right and if your product can help solve
their problems well hey they might be
interested in that right and so if you
speak to them about their problems if
you understand and you have compassion
you understand what people are working
with then you can work backwards to
building an amazing product so divisions
by defining the problem and then you can
work backwards in solving technology got
it and at Apple like it's I think pretty
famously said that you know for every
you know there's a hundred no's for
every yes I would find that to say that
there's a hundred not yet for every yes
but famously if you go back to the
iPhone for example right the iPhone one
every I mean many people laughed at it
because it didn't have 3G it didn't have
copy and paste
right and then a year later okay finally
it has 3G but it still doesn't have copy
and paste it's a joke nobody will ever
use this product blah blah blah blah
blah blah right well year three it had
copy and paste and people stopped
talking about it right and so and so
being laser focused and having
conviction and understanding what the
core problems are and giving the team
the space to be able to build the right
Tech is really important
um also I mean you come back to
recruiting you have to pay well right so
we have to pay industry leading salaries
and have good benefits and things like
this that's a big piece uh we're a
remote first company and so we have to
uh
uh so remote first has a very strong set
of pros and cons on the one hand you can
hire people from wherever they are and
you can attract amazing talent even if
they live in strange places or unusual
places on the other hand you have time
zones
on the other hand you have like
everybody on the internet will fight if
they don't understand each other and so
we've had to learn how to like have a
system where we actually fly people in
and we get the whole company together
periodically and then we get work groups
together and we plan and execute
together and there's like an intimacy to
the in-person brainstorming I guess you
lose but maybe you don't maybe if you
get to know each other well and you
trust each other maybe you can do that
yeah well so when the pandemic first hit
I mean I'm curious about your experience
too the first thing I missed was having
whiteboards yeah right those design
discussions where like I can high high
intensity work through things get things
done work through the problem of the day
understand where you're on figure out
and solve the problem and move forward
yeah
um but we figured out ways to work
around that now with you know all these
uh screen sharing and other things like
that that we do the thing I miss now is
sitting down at a lunch table with the
team yeah the spontaneous things like
those the the coffee the coffee bar
things and the and the bumping into each
other and getting to know people outside
of the transactional solve a problem
over Zoom
and I think there's there's just a lot
of stuff that um I'm not an expert at
this I don't know who is hopefully
there's some people but there's stuff
that somehow is missing on Zoom
even with the Whiteboard if you look at
that
if you have a room with one person at
the Whiteboard and there's like three
other people at a table
there's uh first of all there's a social
aspect of that where you're just
shooting the a little bit almost
like yeah as people are just kind of
coming in and yeah that but also while
like it's a breakout discussion that
happens for like seconds at a time maybe
an inside joke or it's like this
interesting Dynamic that happens that
Zoom you're bonding yeah you're bonding
you're bonding but through that bonding
you get the excitement there's certain
ideas are like complete and
you'll see that in the faces of others
that you won't see necessarily on zoom
in like something it feels like that
should be possible to do
without being in person well I mean
being in person is a very different
thing yeah I don't it's worth it but you
can't always do it and so again we're
still learning and we're also learning
as like Humanity with this new reality
right but um but what we found is that
getting people together whether it be a
team or the whole company or whatever is
worth the expense because people work
together and are happier
after that like it just it just like
there's a massive period of time where
you like go out and things start getting
frayed pull people together and then you
realize that we're all working together
we see things the same way we work
through the disagreement or the
misunderstanding we're talking across
each other and then you work much better
together and so things like that I think
are really quite important what about uh
people that are kind of specialized in
very different aspects of the stack
working together what are some
interesting challenges there yeah well
so I mean I mean there's lots of
interesting people as you can tell I'm
you know hard to deal with too but
you're one of the most lovable the uh uh
so one of the so there's different
philosophies in building teams uh for me
and so some people say higher 10x
programmers and that's the only thing
that whatever that means right
um what I believe in is building
well-balanced teams teams that have
people that are different in them like
if you have all generals and no troops
or all troops and no generals or you
have all people that think in one way
and not the other way what you get is
you get a very biased and skewed and
weird situation where people end up
being unhappy and so what I like to do
is I like to build teams of people where
they're not all the same you know we do
have teams and they're focused on like
runtime or compiler GPU or Excel or
whatever the specialty is but people
bring a different take and have a
different perspective and I look for
people that complement each other and
particularly if you look at leadership
teams and things like this you don't
want everybody thinking the same way you
want people bringing different
perspectives and experiences and so I
think that's really important